I'd rather move in the wrong
direction than not move at all because I
believe that when we step out even if
it's the complete wrong direction God
will turn us to the right direction
because when we do the possible we see
God do the
impossible this is the second time we've
had Samuel speak at one of our
conferences he was excellent last time
and he was excellent this time bring him
along because he's got great knowledge
um and he present in a really humorous
way our guys were really engaged we come
in with nothing and we're going to come
out with nothing our short life here on
Earth is just a glimpse I was really
impressed with the amazing value and
content Samuel gave across the bill so
really great speaker listen to what he's
got to say these chains of Injustice to
set the captives free to clothe the
naked to feed the hungry to preach the
good news of Jesus and that is what I
wanted to do but I needed to use my
entrepreneurial mind set to do it
fantastic five key point to to success
Financial Freedom you need to get his
film bless you see you soon this is
probably the best presentation I've ever
heard if you've got a church event or
Christian Conference and you want your
people to be empowered inspired and
equipped and be able to step into their
coin then speak to me i' love to
[Music]
help